with its cross-border traffic in people
and goods islam khala provides a good
indicator of the problems facing both
afghanistan and iran
the surge of people trying to leave
afghanistan as the taliban took over has
eased in recent weeks a sign according
to those guarding this crossing the
conditions have improved
whatever problems the migrants had they
have been solved
vehicles including trucks are moving
freely again
considering this is such a sensitive
crossing things on the border itself are
pretty relaxed before now we as visitors
would have been held way back several
hundred meters and several fences inside
afghanistan now we are allowed to
approach up to the borderline itself the
last taliban checkpoint is right here
this is where afghanistan ends beyond
here
is iran
and taliban officials were eager to show
us how they are also tackling smuggling
and illegal migration across this 1 000
kilometer border
but in the nearby major city of herrat
there's a constant line of people
outside the iranian consulate hoping to
get visas to leave
and here and throughout the country
makeshift camps of internally displaced
people have sprung up as the new
government struggles to cope
winter is now sitting in if there's any
kind of humanitarian assistance from
whatever country we would appreciate and
accept it
back at the border coming in the
opposite direction is a steady stream of
afghan deportees from iran many are
victims of iran's long-standing program
have forced repatriation because of its
own worsening economic crisis
it's my first time back in afghanistan
after 20 years me and all these people
around me have experienced lots of
problems in iran
but they're now joined by more recent
arrivals who fled after the taliban
takeover actually i was obligated to
leave my country in my house people like
nasa ahmed bahave who accuses iranian
soldiers of mistreating him actually i
was trying to get to europe but at the
time when i was getting to iran i got so
difficulties the soldiers of the border
of iran
have trying to kill you or just to
arrest you when they arrest you they
will punish me they will give you as
punishment as a
animals two months after leaving he's
back where he started but says it won't
be long before he's on the move once
more
rob mcbride al jazeera islam afghanistan